hey guys it's max angelica and vadim and
today we are doing another blind camera
comparison between the brand new pixel
5a and the iphone 12 which is the same
as a 12 mini almost the same as the 12
pro i know that's a flagship but this
thing has the same sensors as the pixel
5 for these shooters and we've also had
a lot of software updates so i'm
personally very excited i shot a bunch
of photos they have not seen them yet so
what are we doing so go ahead and grab a
paper and a pen if you want to play
along and don't forget that if you need
more time you can go ahead and pause the
video and look for yourself all right
let's jump right in what do you guys see
other than an absolutely smoky sad
spokane
uh
more detail on the left i think it
definitely is better from what i can see
now you can see a lot more detail on the
left yeah kills it but it might be like
a little over sharpened to me i don't
know man it kills you just look at the
contacts
yeah tons of details in there compared
to that one i actually don't remember
which one is which for probably a lot of
these okay let's hope that's the phone
that's almost twice the price
no pixel
it looks
second one we got a selfie here yeah the
one on the right absolutely like the one
on the left is way too warm everything
that has like a warm tint to it and of
course sky's blown out i do agree
although the details almost look crushed
in the right one like in his eyes hair
and shirt
pixel again pixel again so far pixel is
going so how can the iphone 12
still blow out that with the a42 mix no
processing makes no sense all right we
got an ultra wide here
honestly i like the one on the left it
just feels more lively and colorful the
one on the right just seems too cool and
kind of dark and crushed and like
depressing
iphone 12 finally one for the iphone and
we have a zoom shot yeah one on the
right there's so much easy like noise on
the left easy tons of noise and just
yeah it doesn't look as good that is the
pixel 5a now this is actually a zoom
shot indoors and i can't believe the
difference in quality with that zoom
interesting
yeah the ride is so blown out there's
like no saving it yeah it's definitely
blown out but it looks better
like the style of it you know
you gotta have a blown out shot or uh
there's no way i would choose that one i
would choose that one
you don't have to do any editing it
looks awesome it's
nice hey it's artistic it's artistic
honestly i still like it like i would
rather post that no even though it's
blown out honestly it looks better
i should ask you guys what you thought
was what what did you guys think was
which iphone you thought was the eye for
blowing it out all right here we go wow
the one on the right like what did what
did it do like it smeared all the you
could like barely read my fresh basket
here it's super sharp yeah neither of
these cameras have dedicated telephoto
lenses this looks like it actually has
one this looks like it doesn't and that
is the iphone 12. that is incredible
with the algorithm that the pixel is
using for that and we have our first
portrait shot the one on the left looks
much better i like the left one more
yeah the one on the right is just too
dark like details are crushed like in
her eyes
hair in the background and it's too cool
way too cool iphone 12 iphone 12. and we
got a ultra wide here okay this is kind
of interesting the left one is much more
saturated yeah honestly but i think i
see more detail in it i think so if you
just look at these shrubs bushes trees
you could definitely see more detail
everywhere here even in all like the
water you can actually see you know
everything looks more lively
pixel five eight interesting thing is
this thing has a 16 megapixel ultra
white but it does not look bad look at
that that was a cool artistic shot
interesting i like the one on the right
more the left one just looks too dark in
the mids and the highs honestly i'm
gonna go with the left i think i see a
little bit more detail in her like her
hand uh in the flower here yeah
that's all i'm going to do that's it
pixel 5 iphone 12. we got a macro shot
here even closer oh the left one yeah
the left one looks beautiful just the
colors pop like it really brings out
look at these like little fuzzies on it
super sharp yeah
iphone 12 for macro
whoa yeah the one on the right looks
much better because there is way too
much contrast in over sharpening
sharpening in this like this building
just looks so ugly and all these details
too fake yeah definitely so right iphone
12 so this is actually a standard shot i
cropped in just so we can see the detail
at this distance hard to see but
definitely the iphone kills it maybe
that's deep fusion yeah fortress shot
right here a wider style one the right
one oh yeah of course the right one
looks so much better you don't like that
darkness the left one is so dark
the portrait mode messed up right here
oh okay yeah in between here between
messed up multiple areas and just like
his face like the exposure of his face
is just too dark yeah it's too
underexposed a lot of these yeah so
iphone 12 so it's interesting it's
consistently like
dark and contrasty for these yeah and we
have another portrait shot here this
time without a this is a portrait
subject
portrait i know yeah the one on the left
looks much better in terms of the uh
blur edging yeah you can see here it got
the cracks i can't believe that it got
that that is this is tough this is like
a torch
this one couldn't handle it all of these
areas you have blur right here but you
have no blur
right here but then no blur and then
whatever that's a fail yeah
iphone 12 so apple fine remember when
they used to suck at this yeah they used
to suck at this they finally got it
right with software updates we got
another portrait shot here except for
indoors very tough mixed lighting they
both look pretty good i am gonna go with
the one
on the right a couple of reasons i like
how it's a little bit brighter and uh
the blur looks really nice i'd say
there's a little bit more blur than on
the left and i also like the extra
kind of bokeh
effect look of the lights the left one i
think looks pretty good in this but on
the right one you can definitely tell
like they stand out they're definitely
the center of the picture it looks more
kind of like a dslr yeah that's what you
want to see you want to see
you know the subject there
iphone iphone 12. pulling ahead all
right wait it's going to get interesting
guys
whoa so here you go i'm not going to say
anything what do you guys see it picked
up so much detail on the back
and it's like much less blown out on
those lights
however which photo do you like better
however i don't like that about it once
again because this really stands out so
what happened here was that the one on
the right isn't a portrait mode photo
it is
okay it's supposed to be
it didn't work obviously so if you're
trying to really like make the car pop
it's definitely the one on the left
definitely pops in i was trying to get a
cool cool car shot that was my
yeah this is crazy it looks like it's
picking up more detail in the background
than actually here because if you look
at actual text
do you think it misspoke
oh interesting yeah it is kind of blurry
they didn't get rid of that laser auto
focusing system on this one yeah i don't
know why
maybe that's it yeah i mean interesting
maybe that's why the portrait mode
didn't work maybe i only saw it later
but it wasn't able to do portrait from
this distance
iphone 12 okay
and it got dark yeah what the heck
happened here man
what
it's so dark yeah that failed oh my god
no that's like double bad first of all
everything's crushed everything is
crushed on top of that shoes you have
flaring from the light going across
complete fail
wow
oh night mode yeah we're getting into
the night mode so oh no i don't remember
which one is which
this is hard i think i like the left one
more because it's much less blown out
especially you can tell over here for me
it's the right one for sure just because
of the detail because if you look up
close this is all just soft and kind of
blurry whereas that has tons of sharp
details i also don't remember which ones
which for this but for me i like that
like this is the subject and it really
pops compared to all looking flat and
dark here iphone 12. all right and we
got another night shot here honestly i
think the one on the right looks pretty
bad everything in here is really um
noisy honestly like
they both have downsides like the one on
the right the sky is like brought up so
there's tons of noise visible however
the one on the left there's all this
weird what's it called max artifacts
artifacts artifacts everywhere artifacts
all over here just everywhere so it
really kind of messes with the photo and
the detail gets lost as well compared to
the right one has more detail doesn't
have any artifacting it just has the
extra noise
but overall i'd rather have
the one on the right you'd rather have a
noisy photo i mean it's just a little
bit more noise but it doesn't have any
of this crazy artifact i disagree i
think the noise is much more distracting
i'm going with the right
left
so the iphone lot of noise but clean
portrait shot here
i will say i was very impressed well you
guys choose whichever one you like
better but that to me looked more like a
dslr so i was like what the heck how did
i when i took the photo i was looking at
it yeah i instantly thought the one in
the right it looks really nice yeah
these are very similar but i did notice
that the one on the right is a little
bit more bright and it does have more
detail from what i can tell like in her
face and hair
so it does take the win pixel 5. the
boca looks way more vocal looks so good
and it looks almost looks like what the
iphone did in the day like brighter
warmer and it's like a night they
flipped not for portraits this is dark
and yeah cooler all right look at that
oh
yeah this is just a flare fest right
here you have flaring just going
everywhere where you don't want it it's
way more distracting it just kills all
the detail and the clothes jack jack and
everything
i kind of like that shot artistically it
is more artistic yeah but it's more
silhouetting it just pops less realistic
but more active but i like how you could
actually see some dark sky here it's
actually black and yeah i just don't
like how the whole image is warm
everything's warm here it has some you
know okay don't convince me right i have
my pigeons i'm sticking to the
pixel 5 pixel that's some good night
mode and bam yeah the one on the right
kills it it just it's not impacted by
the flaring whereas flaring you can just
see lines here yeah and it just kind of
affects the image and it becomes soft
where this is super man that's a killer
shot right there it's a nice shot it's
really good
iphone 12. and wait a
minute okay wait was he moving
yeah he was moving him both he would not
stop kids move
kids move you know at night
well then the left was pretty impressive
i will say this is a very tough shot
first off he would not stop moving
second we have a light right above
causing a bunch of flaring and it's dark
this is like nightmare scenario but i
wanted to capture elon on there if he
wasn't moving in this shot i would have
picked it percent i actually took both
hundred percent we're taking at the same
exact time yeah but because
his face is smeared then the left one
wins
iphone 12. yeah the iphone 12 takes nice
night shots twice as quick or even more
like usually one second two seconds
where this thing i'm standing there
waiting waiting yeah
what the heck
you can't see anything here you're not
supposed to see it it's from night time
come on
that's terrible yeah
yeah
yeah that's just garbage right one for
sure yeah
pixel 5a this is ultra white so
literally at night it started flipping
ultra wide looks amazing look at all
that deep i'll point that are you guys
doing that
look at that this is an amazing shot you
want to have what do you see there up
there on the on that pole on the pole on
the pole i guess neither of them are
good enough
let's see which one is the best but
that's actually an owl that like flew in
we're like what is that it flies in and
it was super dark i can't even tell and
then we we're like is that real and
awesome the head turns all the way
around or like
no yeah it's the one on the right wins
hands down not even not even a
competition just just looking at the
grass on the yeah this is all smeared
there's no contrast between it shadows
and the funny thing is this is a one
second photo compared to like a four
second photo really i'm like standing
there
please don't fly away
iphone 12.
no guys this is good
this is a horror movie that we're trying
to take photos
where did the red come from
um
what in the world that's the was it it
wasn't using the stream wasn't using
flash so neither of them are technically
using flash and yeah i was shocked by
this difference i actually took this
photo wow that
whatever phone this is
was just one time that's good this one i
did four or five times um so really this
phone actually shines a little bit of
light but like a dim yellowish light
uh-huh not flash if you do flash it's
like blinding this one you either have
the option of flash where it's like in
your eyes crazy blinding and the photo
is like super ugly
or you use night mode
and that is what you get it was really
dark though but this is reality i took
like i don't know three four shots and
then i tried the flash it's completely
different that's so bad i can't believe
that's real yeah how is it a real photo
and there's no flash on here uh a little
it shines a little bit so if you put
flash it's like
and this is like a tiny bit of light
that like comes in just from the display
from the display yeah okay it looks so
scary i mean this one's obvious yeah
yeah wow i'm really surprised we
complained for years about iphone
selfies at night you either flash and
look at this
yeah and then now it looks better than a
year ago when we first tested it almost
a year ago and i know apple doesn't tell
people that like hey we make quick
camera upgrade upgrades like uh google
does and samsung does but they've made a
lot of improvements so that is the
iphone 12. that's crazy how's that real
how is that photo real yeah so
that is it that is our last image if you
guys follow along play along with us
pause the video count up your results
let us know we want to know what you
guys voted for and
this thing i just set it up as i shot it
i know the sensors and the software is
great on the google google phone the
pixel i haven't seen what your guys's
results are
but i was not expecting this big of a
difference in the past it was so close
with the pixel 5 and then the iphone 12.
so all right if you guys voted that's
good yeah if not let's wait
all right angelica what did you get i
got 16 for the iphone 12 and 9 for the
pixel 5a 16 and 9. and vadim 17 for the
iphone 8 for the pixel for the pixel how
in the world did we get such a big
difference between these huge is google
limiting this more did they make the
software worse i don't know man
i don't know either uh it's kind of
weird i don't remember what we got last
time with the pixel 5. i know it did a
lot better than this so strong suits
ultra rider is good at night uh yeah but
in the daytime a lot of those just too
cool too underexposed you guys let us
know your thoughts software what one and
why what were your why did you guys
choose certain photos uh we want to hear
that thank you guys for watching you
guys can click that circle above to
subscribe it will also help us reach our
goal of a million subscribers before the
end of the year that'd be amazing check
out one of those great videos over there
this has been max angelica and vadim and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]